hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
it's been a while hasn't it since we've
seen these map changes but now they have
come back to the world of fortnight so
we can begin our weekly meetups again if
you want two bad days let me know so
relax for 10 minutes
slap coder tomorrow in the fortnight
shop and let's uncover all the large and
small changes to our new home here in
fortnight chapter 2 oh and if you're new
around these parts please think about
subscribing the deal is if we reach 1
million subscribers before the end of
the year I will reveal my ugly face I
know it's not really much of an
incentive anyway it's enough
self-promotion let's do this
[Music]
it's Halloween the map has changed
massively there are so many areas to
look at but one is far more important
than all the others combined the bunker
you know this place is integral to the
story I know this place is integral to
the story and has anything happened here
yet hell no but we're still gonna check
next week
Funko Watch is the new hot watch I don't
think it'll catch on okay so I'll be
serious now I promise the biggest
changes to the map comes at the lodge of
the center island the wood has now been
replaced with Kevin's corruption and you
can now fight the Storm King from save
the world it's such an amazing fight
with friends the map is very similar to
that in save the world but this fight
has been streamlined and with 12 players
it's just a great LTM I challenge you to
beat this bad boy with a squad of
bananas
here's team potassium first attempt
we failed badly and to quote Gwen
Stefani this is bananas be again a na
yes yeah who thought you'd get a Gwen
Stefani reference in this god I need to
get a life anyway your reward for this
is this lovely glider which is damn cool
so zombies are back but luckily they
cannot touch water without dying
so we are safe right well hell no zombie
sweat can now be found living in cars
and other hiding spots in the world
giving you a heart attack the first time
you see them what's awesome to me though
is watching it in slow motion look so
cool and come on you can be honest here
did the jump scare get you the first
time
you liar so this part of the year is
referred to as fought nightmares but if
we go back to Gotham last season which
feels like years ago now we had Clues at
the cinema the posters around the joint
were direct clues about future character
skins hiding in plain sight brilliant
work epic games as I'm sure you've
already noticed every single corner of
the map is now covered in Halloween
decorations if you need to see them all
I'll put them in some sort of montage at
the end of the video but some are more
noteworthy than others for example over
in frenzy farm next to the building
under construction is a big-ass barn
inside it's a partay it's really well
put together in here so definitely worth
a look if you're in this region next
time you're in a game or in retail row
the store has returned once again the
major update here of course is these the
wacky waving inflatable arm tube llamas
the wacky waving inflatable arm tube
thomas the wacky waving inflatable arm
tube llamas hopefully you get that
reference otherwise I sound like I have
issues and I do the star looks almost
ready to open with extra stock coming in
around the back and shelves packed with
pointless rubbish we all waste our money
on at this time of the year
maybe we should all buy a tree instead
hashtag team trees a few days before the
update one building just outside retail
gave us a clue about the future it was
subtle but here in this innocent
building our ghosts
operations if you spotted it gee-gees to
you I didn't so I need to thank someone
in my discard critical thank you very
much for showing me this much
appreciated
between craggy cliffs and steamy stacks
is a group of houses by the edge of land
likely they're going to fall into the
ocean this season visit this to witness
some weird-ass shizzle including three
spiders about to take down a teddy and
you know what to do here do the right
thing and save the little hairy bugger
right in the fields and one last
Halloween update worth a mention south
of the lighthouse is this a gnome with a
flock of spiders chapter 2 has given us
a Shepherd gnome and also if you visit
here you get extra look against those
sweaty players trying to go pro another
awesome update I saw walking around the
map are the gargoyles but they hold a
secret randomly they can do this I'll be
honest I slightly pooped my pants the
first time I saw that and one must
update before we move on from Halloween
and bought nightmares
the floating furniture around the map
when struck a ghost-like blur appears
briefly I'm sure you've seen it keep an
eye on it though because this blur can
become a ghost
check this what's even more interesting
is the ghost changes character and this
got me thinking what if epic games
leaked a new skin through these ghostly
pop-ups so use the comments below
- say what skins you've seen floating in
the furniture
okay with that out of the way it's time
to start something new a new section for
this video it's time for the erection
inspection the erection inspection I
know I need to I need to work on a
better title but come on in a few weeks
you're gonna want a t-shirt with
erection inspection written on it to go
to school in try explaining that to your
parents around the map our building
sites with unfinished directions this
series will be updating you on all your
favorite directions as they grow I am
doubling down on double entendres this
season I hope you can put up with it
there are three to pay close attention
to the building behind the farmhouse
which remains unchanged the building in
sandy shores which again hasn't budged
but the third is already complete in the
same location no less when we started
chapter 2 there was a pier but it was
incomplete but now check it out we have
a sign beautiful honestly these little
map updates keep me coming back every
week does anybody else feel the same
just beyond this the construction trucks
are moving on and the flatbed with the
digger on has already hit the roads
where will it go next could it go around
the corner and work on erection number 2
or will we follow this bad boy around
the map in future weeks I can't wait to
find out so that was our new section
erection inspection I hope you liked it
the erection inspection
[Music]
there's a few spots I missed in the last
update video which I think we should go
over right now how much time do you
spend in lazy lake did you know that
there's a secret inside this building
make your way down to the man cave or
lady lair at the foot of the
Foundation's and now knock through the
wall with the TV on it and you'll
discover two more chests hiding here but
that's not the end of this break the
next wall to burrow through to the next
house that's right those two houses are
connected so you can sneak up on a foe
who has no idea you're in the house
happy days speaking of Secrets one I
missed last week which loads of you told
me about is found at camp cot the main
house is filled with loads of chapter 1
memorabilia
it's bloody everywhere but did you know
there are two secret rooms here hidden
behind bookcases the one in the living
room unveils a secret bunker with comms
and chests and a bit of ammo too but
that's not the end of it
smash the furniture in the center of the
room and walk over the carpet a
super-secret extra layer with the chests
and ammo and not a bad hiding place to
throw down a trap if you ever come down
here you'll be surprised how often it
grants you a kill it's pretty good
[Music]
other things that we should note on the
map the monitors in the airplane broken
in the northern islands now flicker with
life every so often suggesting a message
will be displayed on these later in the
season so let's keep an eye on that oh
and at this point I usually have a crack
in a story line but I don't really have
one at the moment I've got a few ideas
the biggest one though is a reference to
the comic book TV show and figurines GI
Joe they remade them into a film
recently as well well Eagle looks a lot
like Cobra from that series and even the
skins bear resemblance such as Snake
Eyes and his arch-nemesis
Storm Shadow so I'll think about it and
I'll build on that next week if you
notice anything I don't on the map or
you have a crack at a story please get
in touch with me on Twitter or better
yet join our discard we have lots of
channels for lots of different things to
talk about
as usual here is the legends roll call
thank you guys for using my code a
tomorrow in the fort night shop you
allow me to make videos like this with a
little bit of personality too thank you
very much I love you for it if your name
isn't here then don't worry I'm running
a little bit behind but you will be here
and I will reply to you so check it next
video right thanks for your time I'm
going to expect some Corrections I'll
see you all next time I shall leave you
with me and the psg discord community
having a crack at the storm king it went
quite well considering see you soon
this is it
[Applause]